-Here's how this works.
On your turn,
your partner puts on a pair of
noise-canceling headphones.
Then, you select a clue
from the board.
They're all very popular songs.
And once your song
starts playing,
you have to lip-synch it out,
or act out the lyrics,
to get your partner
to guess the song.
I'll go first.
You guys go and take your seats.
And here's your headphones.
-Okay.
-And then, when you sit down,
turn it on,
and it's really loud.
-Oh, gosh.
-Yeah.
-[ Clears throat ]
-All right.
You're going down, Kravitz.
-Oh, yeah!
That's what I'm talkin' about!
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yes, that's what I'm
talkin' about!
-Yeah!
-You're going down, Kravitz!
-Both Kravitzes.
-All right.
Uh, all right, what, 7?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Whoo!
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-All right, here we go.
[ Clears throat ]
3...2...1.
-♪ Go on now, go,
walk out the door ♪
-You're going down.
"Timber," "Timber"! No? Okay.
"I'm Walkin' Away."
"Don't Walk Away, Boy."
No, "I Wanna Take a Walk
on the Wild Side."
Uh, uh, uh, uh,
"A Guy Told Me
to Walk This Way."
No. Uh, yeah.
Oh, "Disco Fever"!
Or "Saturday Night Fever"!
Or -- Or...
No, "You're Out," "You're Out."
"I'm In."
"I Don't Know
What to Play With."
"I Can't Handle This."
"This Is So --"
"You're So Strong."
"You're My Favorite."
[ Buzzer ]
-Ohhhh!
-That was an epic fail.
All right, sorry, it's done.
-Did I get it?
-I'm sorry, that was
"I Will Survive."
-[ Gasps ] Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
-I was just terrible.
I'm so sorry.
Don't even talk. I'm sorry.
-I don't even know what to say.
-Don't even say anything, okay?
This never happened.
Look at the Kravitzes.
They're neither one impressed.
Dude, I've never seen you
more disappointed in me
ever in my entire career.
-I'm not upset.
I'm just disappointed.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the best.
All right, Lenny, you're up.
Zoe, put on the headphones.
-Okay.
-Here we go.
-I'm up?
-Yep.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, one more.
All right, so, I just -- Oh.
-Wait, I have to push "play."
-Read that.
-Yeah, push "play."
And it's a terrible song.
[ Laughter ]
-Do I have to count?
-Oh, yeah, you have 3.
-3, 2, 1.
-♪ Ow, she's a brick house ♪
-"Go." "House."
"The House."
-♪ She's mighty-mighty ♪
-"She's Strong."
-♪ Just lettin' it all
hang out ♪
-"Got Big Boobs."
"She's A Brick"!
"She's a Brick House"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aah! Aah!
Aah! Aah!
-Aah!
-Whoo!
-Oh, my God! Played!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man!
-Come on! So mad!
-Both.
-Your brick was good,
your brick was good!
-Aw!
All right, come on.
-Damn you Kravitzes!
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
Kravitzes!
-Nice.
-Here we go.
Reese, we're gonna do it
this time.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Okay.
Oh! Okay.
-Okay, it looks good.
-Okay.
-You look very positive.
We can do this.
All right, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's 3, 2, 1.
-Uh-oh.
-All right.
-Oh, 3, 2, 1.
-♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
♪ And I'll rise
like the break of dawn ♪
♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
-"Let It Go."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-"Let It Go"!
♪♪
Ha ha ha!
-All right, all right.
-I knew it! Reese is back!
-Okay.
-Wow!
-See how we play?
That's how you play the game.
-Oh, yeah, I'm gonna show you.
Is it my turn?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo, that was awesome!
I really got it.
-All right, I got to do it
like this.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-And then turn it on.
-Is it on, is it on?
-Oh, I got to turn it on?
-Here you go.
-Dad, this is your speaker here.
-Oh!
-Yeah.
-That's not cool, man.
-It's my new record.
Come on, dude.
-Lucky number. Take that in.
-Okay.
-Okay. [ Laughs ]
Original.
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-♪ I'd fly above the trees ♪
♪ Over the seas in all degrees ♪
♪ To anywhere I please ♪
-"Flying." "Flying"?
-♪ Oh, I want to get away ♪
-"Fly Away"?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw, that's cheating.
That's not fair.
[ Cheers and applause
continue ]
That is cheating!
That's his song!
-I mean...
-It would have been
so embarrassing
if you didn't get that song.
-I didn't think it was gonna be
one of my songs.
-If I had a hit song,
I would have had one on there.
All right, me and you,
this is the showdown right here.
-2-1, by the way.
-Yeah, I know,
but this last one...
-Oh.
-You both do together?
-...you earn 10,000 points.
-Ah.
-10,000?
-We both go together.
You guys, headphones on.
Listen to the new
Jimmy Fallon track.
It's really good.
-[ Laughs ]
-Is it on?
-Wait, wait. Okay.
-Are we both doing...
We're gonna do "3, 2," and
then lip-synch at the same time.
And whoever...
-Do you know what song you have?
-No, I don't know it yet.
We're gonna do this.
-Okay, well, come on.
-Ready?
-Yeah.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-You know that?
-Yeah, a little bit.
Yeah, I know it.
-Okay.
-But, yeah.
-What's happening?
-Okay. Okay.
-Great.
-Are we ready?
3, 2, 1.
-♪ Don't speak ♪
-"Don't Speak."
-Yes! Oh, my God!
-Ohhh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Turned it fast!
-Oh, my God!
-Say, "My God"! [ Laughs ]
-What was it?
Oh, my God! "Don't Speak"!
-"Don't Speak."
-"Don't Speak"!
Right on the money!
-You're fast!
-That was too fast.
-Fast! Oh, no!
Zoe! Oh, no!
Oh, no!
You finally lost on our show!
Oh, no! [ Laughs ]
-That is not cool.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you to Reese Witherspoon
and Lenny Kravitz, Zoe Kravitz!
We're talking to Lenny
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
-Ugh-ugh-ugh.